これはバターにまつわる話である高校時代に僕は映画化の売店でバイトをしていたある
日とてつもなく太っている白人女性が僕の0時に行ってきて
バターたっぷりのポップコーン large でといった
やっぱりという言葉を飲み込むと僕はかしこまりました少々お待ち下さいと言って
ポップコーンを作り始めた後で大きいポップコーンの袋
保持しとかなきゃいけないなぁと思いながら機械的に体を動かしているとふと気がつい
た彼女はまじまじと僕の手を見つめていたのだ
何何と思いながらポップコーン袋に入れ普通に会社を備えバターぽんぽ4回もして
ポップコーンにバターをかけた振り返ってクジラをなに渡した
たっぷりって言ったでしょ
もうちょっとかけて bully 無理無理と思いながらはいかしこまりましたと言っ
た僕は袋を受け取ってもう一度バターポンプをし始めた子回目
6回目人口バターがそそがれるたびに少しずつポップコーンが重くなっていくのを
感じると僕の目に涙が浮かんでくるのが分かったブリース折衝の方に向き直って
ポップコーンをカウンターの上には入ったサンドになりますその上アコ
ドル札を渡してきたフレを受け取って1ドル札を取り出している時だとちょっとはざけ
んなよもうないし消えてくれ
かけてくれるかなぁ
かしこまりました世界一軽いの高いポップコーンを二人を受け取って僕はもう一度
パターンポンプをし始めたな回目8か今17歳の若さで僕人殺しになるんだと思うと
とても暗い気分だったありがとうと彼女は少し不満そうな顔しながらポップコーンを
受け取ってやっと去っていた僕はしばらく油まみれのカウンターに映っている自分の巣
が
ぼんやりと並べていた2前のドンドンドンという足音に思わず顔を上げた
あの旗じゃないよねはいここって水は無料だったかな
指先から張り詰めていた力がすっと抜けていくのを感じた
無料ですよ差し上げましょうかということは水菜カップの無料ってことですよね
そうですがバターを買って行ってくれないかなこれじゃあやっぱりまだ足りないは僕が
震える手でカップを取り出すと彼女は僕を見てもらった私
ポップコーンにバターをかけるのダメな人などの困惑しと僕は思う柄を開けた
はいバターにポップコーンをかけるほうが好きな人なの
ええええええ